[موسيقى]
حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل ابو سرور ابو سرور هذا ابو سرور
ابو سرور هذا حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل ابو
سرور ابو سرور الله يرحمه يا عم معها منا
الله ير في معها مناس يا ولد قلي فهمه
عنها ايش قاللك فهمه في مع املات اذا
بتقدر تطلع هي هي جاكيته هي جاكيته الحمرا
ايته يا عم مش قادر لا بقت بشها لا ما
بقدرش جكيت الحمرا
هذ استنى يا حاج حاج اتاكد تاكد برضه يا
حاج ايوه بعينك الله تاكد اسب اتاكد ايوه
تاكد تاكد جلابيه هذه يا زلمه جلابيه ايش
لونها سمراء هذ سمرا ام سروور هذه ام
سروور تعال ارفع هيك بل عن جد اه والله ه
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل ايه يابا مبين يا
حاج يا
عم هي هي شوف هو مش عارفي ه هيها ماسكه ما
اتاكد منها طب ارفع من فوقها طب هاتلي هاط
ريه كريك هاتوا
حاجه بلوزه بلوزه هذه لا
[موسيقى]
لا لا ايش هذه لا يابا يا عم ابدي هيك اب
هيك لش
ه اي اسحب لا ايش ه
متاكد يا عم
فيغ تفاجانا
اليوم اثناء تنظيف
لمدرسه
حمل في شمال قطاع غزه بجوار الاندونيسي
لاكتشاف مقبره داخل المدرسه مقبره جماعيه
ضم اكثر من 50 او 60 جثه جزء من ها الجثث
لشهداء فلسطينيين من شمال غزه معصبين
الاعين رب
موثقين الايدي بالكلبشات
البلاستيك و حاطينهم في اكياس بلاستيك سمر
اثناء التنظيف كان قوم الطراب داخل
المدرسه تفاجانا انه داخل كومه التراب هاي
كل ها جتك فتحنا عن احدى القياس يعني ليش
نن اللي عرفنا انه هي
موثوقه الاعين وال والايدي
والارجل فتحنا عن كيس من الكياس ووجدناه
متحللين الجثث متحلله والرباطات البلاستيك
موجوده على ايديهم والغم الشرا الشريطه
موجوده على
عيون يا الله حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل
الوارس فارس فارس
فك حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل اطلع
فوق
الله